Walter Isaacson as we were talking about
has made a career out of writing about
the world's greatest innovators the
best-selling authors behind biographies
of iconic figures like Steve Jobs Albert
Einstein and Benjamin Franklin now
Isaacson is the host of a new podcast it
is called trailblazer in each episode
explores the recent disruptors and
innovators who revolutionize industries
and transform lives welcome back thank
you it's good to be back with you
Charlie I was following in the footsteps
trying all forms of media so why did
make the decision to do that and what
are you all think that other people are
not offering in Europe well you know I'm
not really paid too much attention to
podcasts you know I see people doing it
but like you I try to learn each new
form of media you know I opened up a
drawer recently not one of those little
blackberries I had to wind up you know
from 30 years ago so when they came
along Pacific content and Dell
technology said hey we want to do a
really well produced podcast that tells
the stories of disruption and innovation
I thought well that's good
podcasting can help save storytelling
which is something that we're sort of
threatened in the ditch one of the
things you've written is called the
innovators I think yeah so that's been a
subject as well yeah you know it's like
okay I've written about it and might as
well do you know try it firsthand and
the innovators tells a story you know
throughout the digital age of how things
transformed and we think it's all new we
think you know Airbnb is the first great
technological disruption of the hotel
industry no I mean that happened when
ends were replaced by standardized
hotels because we got the automobile so
I just want to show that how the history
of disruption occurs and that's sort of
best done through storytelling can I
just say this Walter you're great
storytelling ability continues on your
podcast because you open every single
one with a little story little tease and
then you draw us in I really got engaged
with the Domino pizza story because I
said it was 2000 whatever and it's a man
and a woman they do something gross at
Domino's I know and it goes viral
because they put the video up because
they've had it which yeah it was a gross
act but then Patrick Doyle comes in and
says we have a problem here and he does
something that nobody had ever done
before he admitted we
mistakes and totally change the company
around well it's very important to be
able in this digital age when things go
viral to pivot very quickly and say
here's a mistake here's how we're going
to fix it and what he also does is he
realizes he's not just to put cheese on
top of a bread company
he's a technology company you know you
should be able to tweet him that you
want a pizza
I remember 1994 this is how old I am I
remember what the first time the first
thing you could order online the first
thing you do was pizza yeah you know and
that was you know and before Amazon but
Patrick even says we're a tech company
that just happens to do pizza which I
never thought of it that way right and I
think every industry has a start
thinking about them you know when we're
a tech company that happens to run
hotels were a tech company that happens
around an airline I mean what you're
doing is customer relations and this is
how the disruption happens in all these
industries we talk about and the people
who did at Pacific content and Dell
technologies they kind of produced it
very well I don't take any credit for
that but their sound effect and so it's
like let's bring podcasts to the next
level so I know on netflix one of the
true disruptors of our time and it's
such a great story because we even
forget I've even forgotten we used to
get the discs in the mail
oh no man they were able to change so
big disruptive themselves with that dad
no I mean that CEO Gail has a really
good point because what Reed Hastings is
able to do
I remember when Steve Jobs did this with
the iPod to the iPhone but Reed Hastings
was able to do is he created a business
based on the desk would get me I would
get to your house and then he said
streaming is coming along let's
cannibalize our old business to make
sure nobody else cannibalizes I have
much time left you're from New Orleans
you went from there to a scholarship
there's great controversy in your
hometown now yeah some of the shell
Miller's wonderful piece that y'all had
on today bringing down the monuments and
I think it's very important I think
mayor Landrieu has done a very good job
because some of these monuments we'll
just put up in the 1880s 1890's not to
commemorate Jefferson Davis who had very
little to do with the city of New
Orleans and he was taken down last night
they were put up
you know to send a signal after
reconstruction I think New Orleans has
always had an amazing diversity and you
know Michelle Miller being example of
somebody who's from New Orleans married
to a former mayor that diversity has to
be nurtured it gave us our Jazz's gave
us our jambalaya our food and when you
have monuments that say to certain
people you shouldn't feel included in
the history of the city I think it's
good that we're moving them and I think
it's good that the mayor is doing
methodically wait Abby you always always
good be with you when you come back in
October when your if you invite me back
for Leonardo da Vinci I can just tell
you what a cool guy do you would okay
only playful we always like to have you
here
you know how to do so many things yeah
you know the connection of the science
to the art is the key to innovation five
hundred years ago when he lived and
today we'll talk about it in October yes
we will see you in October